joining us now is IBM Vice chairman Gary
Cohn president of Goldman Sachs during
the financial crisis 15 years ago and
then the top economic advisor in the
Trump Administration during a key moment
of deregulation which we'll talk about
in a moment but Mr Cohen first for
people at home who are still trying to
figure this out what went wrong well
first of all thanks for having me we had
a classic bankrupt you know it's it's as
simple as that we had a situation where
people got scared about A bank's ability
to return depositors money and deposits
wanted their money out and today a bank
run is different than we imagine a bank
rent today a bank run happens on your
telephone people electronically bank
they hit the buttons on their phone and
automatically they can take all their
money out of the bank banks are not
designed to have deposits leave
instantaneously Banks take in deposits
and they invest them for the long term
to help us grow our economy our economy
is based on banks being able to lend
remember we as consumers we borrow money
to buy houses we borrow money to buy car
Parks we borrow money to buy things on
our credit cards all day long so Banks
do that by taking in deposits and then
reinvesting them in in the economy if
everyone wants to pull their money out
simultaneously that's not how banks are
designed that's not how they were ever
envisioned so Banks reinvest in the
economy by providing loans but they also
make investments of their own and in
2018 uh with the backing of the Trump
Administration and bipartisan support in
Congress there was a loosening of the
rules for small and Regional Banks Banks
with under 250 billion in assets and
they didn't have to do stress testing as
I understand it like they did before did
that rollback allow this to happen no it
didn't so so at the end of the day what
happened here had nothing to do with the
bank's Capital these Banks had enormous
amount of capital and capital is the
ability to absorb loss so nothing that
was done in 2018 would have affected the
outcome here What affected the outcome
here is the fact that no Bank holds
enough cash that when all the depositors
want their money back simultaneously
they don't have it there's a ratio where
banks are obligated to carry a certain
amount of liquidity all of these banks
have had high liquidity ratios but that
really doesn't matter when you have a
technical run on a bank so then if the
2018 rollback would not have prevented
this would not have uh allowed the bank
or or the market to foresee it then it
raises the question of can this happen
again and I want to make it more General
than a a Commercial Bank and go to
Consumer Banks my mom it banks with a
small Bank in West Virginia how can
regular people look at their Banks and
figure out whether this is going to
happen and I know they're insured but
it's still a big inconvenience if you
can't access your money this is why we
have FDIC insurance we have FDIC
insurance and it was put in place for
this exact reason because we do have
runs on banks if we never had a run at a
bank we never would have created FDIC
Insurance the reason FDIC insurance was
created is to protect your mom and my
dad to make them feel comfortable to
leave their money in a bank knowing it's
secure because a government agency is
providing the insurance that they need
to make sure their deposits are there
when they want them and the process is
working so deposits are insured in this
country they have been insured up to 250
000 what the government did over the
weekend and they stepped in is They
removed the cap they said for the next
year we're going to ensure all deposits
up to any number so people today should
feel fairly secure to where they are all
right Gary Cohen you know the tech
sector you know the finance sector and
you know it from a political point of
view so thank you very much for being
here thanks for having me